استنكر الاتحاد والترحيل السلطات الامنيه
قياديا نقابيا اسبانيا بعد وصوله الى مطار
قرطاج مانعه اياه من دخول الاراضي
التونسيه كان يفترض ان يشارك في المظاهره
المرتقبه السبت وفي تعليق على هذا القرار
قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان الاتحاد
حر في تنظيم مظاهرته غدا لكنه ليس حرا في
دعوه الاجانب للمشاركه فيها وهذا امر غير
مقبولا على اي مقياس من المقاييس
لتكن معاملاتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا تحدثت
وسائل اعلام تونسيه عن اعتقال عضوين اخرين
في حركه النهضه ويلاحق القضاء التونسي
المتهم بانهم مسيس نحو 20 معارضا من الصف
الاول بينهم ناشطون واعلاميون ورجال اعمال
وقيادي في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه تعتزم
الجبهه تنظيم مظاهره يوم الاحد للتنديد
بحمله الاعتقالات التي طالت قياداتها بين
ان والي العاصمه تونس قطعت طريق امامها
برفضه اصدار ترخيص لتنظيم المظاهره قائلا
ان شبهه التامر على امن الدوله مرتبطه
ببعض قيادي الجبهه وصفت الجبهه قرر المنع
بالتعسف والباطل مؤكده تحديها للسلطات
لتنظيم المظاهره دون ترخيص من جهتها دعت
حركه النهضه ان وكل القوى الحيه في البلاد
الى التظاهر السلميا يوم الاحد ونددت في
بيان بما سمتها محاولات التضييق وبث
البلبله منذ ان جمع الرئيس قيس سعيد
السلطات بيده عام 2021 وهو في عاصفه
الانتقادات والاتهامات بقمع الحريات
والتفرد بقرارات البلاد المصيريه تدهور
الوضع الاقتصادي وتردي المستوى المعيشي
ضاعف حاله النقمه والغضب لدى التونسيين
باختلاف ماربهم يدافع سعيدا عن نفسه
بالقول انما يفعله قانوني لانقاذ تونس من
الفوضى بعين غير راضيه عبرت اكثر من حكومه
غربيه ومنظمه دوليه عن قلقها من الوضع
الذي الت اليه الحريات وحقوق الانسان في
تونس في مقابله مع الجزيره تحدث الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش عن
ضروره العمل من اجل الحفاظ على
الديمقراطيه في تونس مهد الربيع العربي
وقال ان الراي السياسي لا يبرر اعتقال احد
هل من مجيب صوت الخلافات هو الثابت في
المشهد التونسي المسخن بازمات مفتوحه على
كل الاحتمالات ما عدا الانفراج في
المستقبل القريب